turning to the pandemic a dangerous new
strain of the coronavirus is alarming
scientists around the world the strain
was first found in south africa and that
is where debra potta is in the city of
johannesburg debra good morning
good morning the variant was detected in
the last few days because of a jump in
new cases near johannesburg while
numbers are still low just over 2400
they doubled overnight
this is familiar ground for south africa
a new variant that has once again
sparked fears that it could set back the
fight against the pandemic the new
variant marks a huge jump in the
evolution of the virus since the global
health crisis began the concern it could
be more transmissible and more resistant
to vaccines says public health expert
professor salim abdul karim if this
variant
is as or more transmissible than the
delta variant
it would be very difficult to anticipate
it would do anything different to what
we have seen with delta which is that it
would grow and spread across the world
south african scientists are now working
around the clock to determine just how
bad this new variant is lab results are
still a few weeks away but many
countries are not waiting to find out
with several cancelling direct flights
from south africa overnight the new
variant has largely been detected
amongst young people who have the lowest
vaccination rate in the country karim
stresses it was picked up here first
because of south africa's excellent
variant surveillance and it is true that
other countries that may not have the
same level of diligence
may well have new variant spreading
either this one or others they just
don't know about it
karim stresses that even if current
vaccines are less effective against this
variant they will still provide some
protection against serious illness and
death michelle
deborah powder in johannesburg thank you